una emergencia oceánica así es como
define el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres el estado general de
los océanos en la segunda conferencia de
las naciones unidas sobre este tema
global it is pushing el calentamiento
global está llevando la temperatura de
los ciudadanos a niveles récord creando
tormentas más feroces y frecuentes el
nivel del mar está subiendo las naciones
insulares de baja altitud se enfrentan a
inundaciones al igual que muchas de las
principales ciudades costeras del mundo
estos sitios hindú claro no afirma que
los océanos se enfrentan a una grave
amenaza por el calentamiento global la
contaminación y la significación por
ello unas 7000 personas de 120 países
entre jefes de estado científicos y ong
evaluarán los avances en la aplicación
de una directiva para proteger la vida
marina la conferencia busca adoptar una
declaración que ayudaría a implementar y
facilitar la protección y conservación
de los océanos y sus recursos aunque
está aún fuera del alcance un acuerdo
internacional conocido como tratado de
alta mar que vaya más allá de la
jurisdicción nacional
activistas consternados por el fracaso
de políticas de protección protestaron
en las playas de lisboa jones los
océanos están vacíos estamos capturando
menos peces ahora que hace 30 años con
todos los avances y tecnologías
necesitamos una acción adecuada que no
estamos viendo por parte de nuestros
líderes no sea informar a líderes el
océano cubre alrededor del 70% de la
superficie del planeta genera el 50 por
ciento del oxígeno y absorbe el 25 por
ciento de las emisiones de dióxido de
carbono pero unos 8 millones de
toneladas de residuos plásticos llegan a
las aguas cada año y si no se toman
medidas los polímeros podrían superar a
todos los peces de los océanos en 2050
además al absorber más del 90% del
exceso de calor provocado por el
calentamiento global se han generado
olas de calor marinas masivas que están
acabando con los preciosos arrecifes de
coral indispensables para la
supervivencia de las especies bajo el
agua